[Musique]
cher conviction tu es encore jeune et tu
veux infecter les esprits des humains si
tu veux y arriver je te conseille de
s'inspirer des virus pour proliférer un
virus n'a pas être bon ou mauvais pour
proliférer un virus doit survivre au
système immunitaire de ses hôtes
mais surtout il doit se transmettre
d'hôtes en août
en particulier le rhinovirus a trouvé
une astuce génialissime il fait éternuer
ses hôtes cher conviction si tu veux
devenir viral qu'elle les virus les plus
prolifiques
il nous faudra aussi rester à l'esprit
de taiso tu es être transmises d'hôtes
en othe et pour être transmise à
l'instar du rhinovirus
il te faut faire éternuer les autres que
tu infecte pour que ses hôtes ne
transmette à d'autres hôtes un
éternuement de conviction peut-être un
discours intuit une vidéo youtube
il ya une époque où est cette occasion
de passer d'autant notes étaient une
poignée de rares regroupements sociaux
d'humains souvent autour d'hubert d'un
repas pour continuer à se propager
au-delà des humains présents à
l'évènement social une conviction devait
alors survivre à l'esprit critique des
hôtes pendant toute une nuit et la
gueule de bois du lendemain et attendre
ensuite le mouvement ou encore infectés
par la conviction
l'un des hôtes éternue rats au visage
d'un humain
absent lors de l'événement social de la
veille
à cette époque les convictions comme les
virus voyage et les convictions les plus
populaires devait être similaire ou
virus de l'herpès
elle devait être résistantes au système
immunitaire ou à l'esprit critique de
leurs hôtes
mais les nouvelles technologies ont
changé la donne les convictions ont un
nouveau moyen de transport qui les fait
voyager à la vitesse de la lumière pour
atteindre des hôtes pourtant
géographiquement distants mais surtout
désormais grâce au web
dès qu'un autre était remis la
conviction qu'il éternue contamine un
réseau social bien plus vaste et plus
diffuse que le réseau social des autres
présents autour d'une bière
désormais les convictions non plus à
survivre à la nuit et à la gueule de
bois pour se propager et non plus à
survivre à l'esprit critique de leurs
hôtes
désormais les convictions qui
affecteront le plus grand nombre sont
celles que les autres éternue dès leur
infection
souvenez vous à chaque like chaque
partage là chaque commentaire
vous éternuez les convictions qui vous
on attend les nouvelles technologies ont
surtout changé le jeu qui oppose les
différentes convictions désormais
survivre à l'esprit critique des autres
n'est plus un avantage sélectif
désormais les convictions qu'ils
vaincront au jeu de la conquête était
esprit d hôtes sont surtout celles qui
font éternuer cher convictions de nos
jours si tu veux pas être les autres
convictions et triompher à l'esprit des
hôtes être résistant à leur esprit
critique ne te servira pas ce qu'il te
faut faire c'est faire violemment
éternue été hôte aussi vite que possible
oublie les raisonnements long complexe
et fastidieux oublie les données
collectées par les science empirique est
justifiée par les théories axiomatique
oublie les protocoles expérimentaux
pourtant indispensable pour interpréter
correctement les statistiques issues de
ces protocoles certes ces principes sont
bons pour survivre à l'esprit critique
d'une poignée d'anti réductive mais
survivre à l'esprit critique de
quelques-uns ne te feras pas conquérir
le monde
pour conquérir le monde il nous faut
faire éternuer et et autres quitte à ne
pas survivre à l'esprit critique des
autres que tu fait éternuer inspire toi
des virus de la fièvre hémorragique
comme ebola ces virus excellent
contamination et virevolte d'hôtes en
hôte quitte à perdre les autres déjà
infecté parce que ses hôtes ont oublié
ou parce qu'ils sont morts après avoir
éternué pour faire éternuer et et
hautepierre conviction agit sur leurs
émotions
la sociologie l'empirique le montre
c'est en provoquant la fascination
l'anxiété la condescendance ou la colère
chez ses hôtes que tu les feras éternue
cher conviction présente dix bonnes
raisons de croire en toi et fais croire
que la 7e sera particulièrement
fascinante image doit l'aide d'image
inquiétante effrayante ou choquant et
accompagne toit de musique
conspirationnistes use de sarcasmes et
d'hyperboles pour persuader les autres
que toute alternative à ce que tu
proposes ne mérite rien d'autre que la
moquerie exagère les convictions
antagonistes pour énerver les autres qui
trouve ses convictions contraire
inadmissible
abusent des connotations et des
références symboliques ne l'oublient pas
shark fiction ton but n'est pas de
gagner le coeur de taiso tu ton but est
de les faire éternuer au visage d'autres
hôtes aussi vite que possible
c'est ainsi que des convictions qui
s'accompagnent de textes d'image de
vidéos emotionnellement saisissante se
propage exponentiellement vite à travers
le web
c'est en jouant avec nos émotions que
ses convictions incarné dans les médias
du web devienne virale
mes chers conviction n'oublie pas non
plus que les autres humains sont divers
variés et peu prévisibles si tu veux
survivre à leur microcosme dynamique et
instable là encore je te conseille de
inspiré des virus les virus ont trouvé
une autre astuce génialissime pour
survivre à des populations dynamique et
changeante les virus mutent toi aussi
cher conviction soit capable de muter
soit flexible soit variable les
convictions impossibles à interpréter à
la guise des hôtes seront trop
rapidement refoulés par leur esprit
critique pour survivre cher conviction
laisse-toi faire et et faire partie
haute soit suffisamment fou vague et
interprétable pour que chaque hôte tu
acceptes à sa manière et tu verras cher
conviction que les autres tant bras
seront pleinement les psychologues l'ont
montré ils ont appelé les faits parlent
l'effet barnum est incroyablement
efficace d'autant que rares sont les
autres conscient d'être muni d'un crétin
de cerveau rares sont les autres qui
vaccinent leur hygiène mentale contre
cet effet dévastateur mais dans le monde
moderne les autres humains ne sont
qu'une partie de l'univers que les
convictions peuvent conquérir
de nos jours chaque mission il nous faut
voir le web et le cloud comme de
nouveaux hôtes potentiels inspire toi
cher conviction des virus inter espèces
et profite de tous les autres capables
de thé berger l'avantagent du web et du
cloud c'est que contrairement aux autres
humains leur mémoire est infaillible
une fois que cheikh conviction tu auras
infecté un article d'un grand journal où
la vidéo d'un grand youtuber tu pourras
alors contaminer tous les autres humains
qui accéderont à ses contenus
même si ses hôtes n'accède à ce contenu
que des années après le jour où tu aura
réussi à contaminer le journaliste ou le
youtuber en question le comprends tu
cher conviction les nouvelles
technologies contrairement aux autres
humains n'ont presque ni système
immunitaire ni esprit critique
à l'exception de rares cas ce qui est
sûr youtube facebook ou twitter reste
sur youtube facebook et twitter ces
réseaux sociaux ne lutte pas contre les
convictions infondée que nos esprits
critiques pourraient finir par rejeter
avec le temps ces réseaux sociaux
enregistrés conserva jamais les
convictions qui y ont été diffusées
cher conviction tous les conseils que je
t'ai donné jusque là te permettront de
grandir
cependant cher conviction sache que tu
ne pourras pas conquérir le monde seuls
si ton but est d'être une préoccupation
permanente à l'esprit de thé haute il te
faudra coopérer avec d'autres
convictions
à l'instar des virus et des espèces
animales pour accélérer la croissance
il te faudra développer une relation
symbiotique avec d'autres convictions
collabore avec les conviction déjà
populaire à ceux ci toi la religion au
football au terrorisme au chômage à
l'immigration ou surnaturel à la défense
des libertés ou à la politique
tous ces sujets qui ont déjà proliférer
dans les esprits des autres mais surtout
trouve toi un msis rival un ennemi et
travaillent en symbiose avec cette
conviction quitté contraire donne
l'impression que tout autre doit prendre
position donne l'impression que l'hôte
doit opter pour toi cher conviction ou
pour ton contraire donne l'impression
que tout autre doit choisir son camp qui
doit être avec toi ou contre tours et tu
verras achard conviction à chaque fois
que ton rival gagnera en popularité des
hottes éternue rond de tout leur poids
profites en pour exagérer stigmatisé au
rival profites en pour le caricaturer et
le déshumaniser profites en pour
complètement le décrédibiliser aux yeux
de tes haute dont l'idéal t ôt devrait
trouver son rival stupide débile et
dangereux c'est à ce moment là
énervé par son rival que théo tu t'étais
renoueront avec le plus de violences
et c'est là que la relation symbiotique
que tu entretiens avec ton rival fera
tout son effet plus tu gagneras de
termes plutôt rival en gagnera à son
tour mais surtout plus tout rival
gagnera de terrain plus des hottes et
hermione et plus tu gagneras de terrain
bientôt des autres se regrouperont pour
mieux exagéré critiqué et stigmatisé une
version caricaturale de thau rivale la
nature même de ton rival n'apportera
plus tous ceux qui importera c'est
l'image exagéré stigmatisés et
caricaturés de ton rival qui habitera
des hautes et plus les hôtes de ton
rival tu cries titre on exagère or ou de
stigmatiseront et de caricatures
oeuvrons plus tes autres te confondre
contre vents et marées et surtout des
ternes huron au visage dérape saute
encore inhabitée par toi ou ton evans
ensemble taylor toi est ton rival
régnera en maître absolu et toutes les
autres convictions environ votre place
privilégiée à l'esprit des autres ce
qu'il faut absolument retenir de cette
symbiose entre convictions contraire
c'est que critiquer une conviction peut
en fait la nourrir en fait bien souvent
c'est en critiquant une conviction que
indirectement on la promeut
il ya bien des contextes où défendre sa
conviction permet de lutter contre la
conviction contraire mais nombreuses
sont les situations vous défendre sa
conviction ne fait que renforcer la
conviction contraire si vous voulez
lutter contre une conviction prenais
grand soin de choisir convenablement et
attentionné mans le lieu le moment et la
manière de se faire
[Musique]
maintenant que tu règne cher conviction
devons rester au pouvoir
pour ce faire il reste une dernière
prouesse à accomplir cette dernière
prouesse est peut-être la plus dure à
réussir mais elle te garantir à un
pouvoir durable chez t ôt ce qu'il te
faut faire cher conviction c'est
désormais faire croire à des hôtes
qu'ils t'ont toujours eu à l'esprit ce
qui te faut réussir cher conviction
c'est à amener les hôtes a jugé que de
posséder fait partie de leur identité ce
qui te ferait triompher cher conviction
c'est devenir la vraie entité aux
commandes des faits gestes et pensées de
ses hôtes
ça peut te paraître bien impossible
cercles fictions mais les autres humains
ont encore une autre faiblesse qu'ils
ignorent ils finissent par aimer les
croire vrai ce qui leur est familier
c'est ce que les psychologues appellent
les ans cognitives
est ce que ça signifie pour toi cher
conviction c'est qu'ils te suffit d'
infecté suffisamment souvent l'esprit
d'un autre pour que l'autre finissent
par te cd et pleins pouvoirs taylor tu
seras l'entité aux commandes des faits
gestes et pensée de l'autre
au point que l'autre soit incapable de
penser sans faire appel à toi
raisonner sans toi pourtant que l'autre
ne soit plus rien sans toi
telle est la mission cher correction
dernière fois on a parlé du
communautarisme et gibouin florent nous
fait leur marque et que dans les cours
des années 2000 c'était pas clair en
tout cas dans les labos de sociologie
que j'ai internet allait conduire à une
telle ségrégation idéologique et je
pense que c'est vraiment un point très
très très important vis-à-vis de la
vidéo précédente c'est que c'est ultra
contre-intuitif moi quand j'ai joué au
jeu des polygones pourra parfois que
j'ai été bluffé tout simplement c'est
vraiment très très contre intuitif à
quel point la ségrégation n'est tout
simplement du désir de chacun de ne pas
vouloir être en minorité et je pense que
l'ampleur du phénomène est vraiment très
très très contre intuitive et dépassent
très largement ce qu'on pourrait croire
effectivement en particulier ne sont
plus très très très très peu de gens se
rendent compte à quel point ils sont
dans leur bulle
je sais que ça m'est arrivé de parler
pardon avec des amis qui j'ai fait une
école d'ingénieurs du coup j'ai beaucoup
d'amis qui sont cadres parisiens
typiquement et quand je parle avec eux
mais ils ont l'impression que je viens
d'un autre monde
ce que mon bras j'ai les ai des idées
assez académique à ses six comme vale on
va dire par rapport à pas mal de choses
notamment vis-à-vis des nouvelles
technologies et le rôle qu'elles vont
jouer dans le futur
et du coup ils disent que je suis dans
ma bulle je suis clairement dans ma
bulle je le sais et bien souvent les
gens vont dire revient sur terre revient
dans la réalité comme si les gens
habiter dans la réalité
alors que le monde des cadres parisiens
à paris c'est pas
la réalité c'est une bulle également et
de la même façon chacun d'entre nous
vivons dans notre propre bulle et je dis
ça vraiment pour insister sur le fait
que c'est difficile de se rendre compte
de tout ce qui ne se passe dans le monde
notamment aujourd'hui alors des filtres
bubbles particulier sur les élections
aux états unis mois on nous suit qu'il
était totalement polarisé d'un côté et
quand on combine la vidéo précédente
avec la vidéo qu'on vient de voir ici on
voit bien que voilà il va avoir
forcément deux camps qui vont se poser
soit posée sur une idée idéologique très
stigmatisante et que du coup chacun va
stigmatiser caricature et l'autre chacun
va penser que sa version est la bonne
version de la réalité
wade veut ta copine johann hay nahda et
octo faire le demande pourquoi c'est
important que la société soit mélangé
j'ai jamais dit ça si vous suivez bien
la vidéo précédente j'ai dit que si on
voulait que ce délai soit plus mais en
relais il fallait que c'est ce qui me
fait très peur avec cette série de
vidéos c'est que dès qu'on parle d'un
sujet les gens sur interprète avec son
entente que j'ai un avis politique sur
la chose que j'essaie vraiment juste de
décrire des liens de cause à effet il
suit logique de conséquence des espèces
de deux processus qui se passe dans nos
sociétés et de voir à partir de quelles
hypothèses on à quelles conséquences en
particulier si vous prenez les épisodes
2 6 et puis la vidéo que vous venez de
voir mais aussi les vidéos qui vont
venir plus tard ce que j'essaie de vous
montrer dans cette vidéo c'est qu'elles
sont les quelques hypothèses notamment
les changements de structure de sociétés
qui ont été impliqués par les nouvelles
technologies qui conduisent à cette
bipolarisation idéologique mais aussi le
problème bien sûr des scrutins dont j'ai
parlé dans l'épisode 2 il ya quand même
des choses à dire en tant que théoricien
des jeux sur le fait que la bi
polarisation idéologique ou jeu pas
forcément la bipolarisation comme le
font remarquer certains mais juste le
fait que les gens commencent à avoir des
idées extrêmes dans des communautés très
éloignés les uns des autres posent des
problèmes sur le vivre ensemble
notamment l un des problèmes qu'il ya
c'est que chacun vit du coup dans sa
bulle et ne connaît de l'autre qu'une
image stigmatiser caricaturer et tout ça
du coup il semble que ça à ça pourrait
avoir tendance à diminuer la tolérance
des uns aux autres et en particulier ça
risque de conduire
ces chiffres là par exemple aux états
unis les libéraux pensent que les
conservateurs sont très dangereux et
vice et versa et ce genre de
d'incompréhension n'est aussi du fait de
cette polarisation et de cette
ségrégation idéologique ne soit pas
important c'est que lorsqu'il ya deux
gros plan comme ça celui qui va être
légèrement plus grands va avoir le
pouvoir
du coup les décisions vont être
entièrement pour ce groupe et aux du
coup au détriment de l'autre groupe
alors que si la société était plus
mélangées du coup la décision de la
majorité serait forcément plus
équilibrée elle pourrait pas être autant
au détriment de l'autre groupe a prise
de décision collective
c'est beaucoup mieux d'avoir un
équilibre entre deux idéologies
antagonistes plutôt que avoir deux clans
très divisés auquel cas la majorité sera
forcément dans l'un des deux camps et ce
sera l'un des deux corps qui va dicter
les lois à l'autre camp et ça ça donne
en a vraiment l'impression qu'il ya une
grosse partie de la population qui
subiraient la loi imposée par l'autre
partie de la population un autre point
intéressant qui est soulevée par une
fleur qui entend c'est que ce phénomène
de ségrégation il n'y a pas vraiment
quoi que ce soit à voir avec les
problèmes classiques de racisme ou de
religion le problème surtout que une
fois qu'il ya quelque chose qui divise
une conviction et souvent antagonistes
qui semble régner dans l'esprit des
documents et ce moment là les gens vont
se regrouper entre deux clans et cette
chose qui divise ça peut être n'importe
quoi c'est pas forcément des problèmes
de racisme ne s'est pas forcément des
problèmes d'idéologie ça peut être aussi
des poèmes j'espère de richesse de sexe
à chaque fois qu'il ya de ces sujets qui
polarise énormément et chacun peut
s'identifier facilement à l'un des deux
camps on va voir ce problème de
ségrégation assez rapide
que j'ai décrit dans l'épisode précédent
enfin ce dena services à la personne
propose une autre façon que ça que
j'avais proposée dans l'épisode
précédent pour lutter contre la
ségrégation idéologique ou sociale qui
consiste à ne pas simplifier tous les
débats en 1 une chose polarisantes en
carré triangle il peut avoir aussi les
couleurs de l'été forme il peut y avoir
aussi l'or au bilan passion leur intérêt
plein d'autres choses
en fait nos similarités avec d'autres
personnes ne se décrit pas juste en une
dimension on va dire elles sont
multidimensionnelles
et si je suis hexagonal je peux très
bien entendre avec des cercles cirque le
foot aussi
autrement dit il ya des sujets dans une
société qui divise énormément et ces
sujets là il règne un petit peu à
l'esprit des autres et le fait qu'il
règne pousse davantage à cette
ségrégation idéologique et une façon de
lutter contre ça du coup c'est juste de
promouvoir d'autres thèmes qui
pourraient occuper l'esprit les autres
notamment des thèmes qui parlent
diviserait mois on ne reparlera
notamment mais par exemple pour jonathan
ait fait un psychologue
la meilleure façon de convaincre
quelqu'un sur un sujet politique c'est
d'abord devenir proche de lui pour une
autre raison par exemple parce qu'on a
un hobby commun et puis années au sujet
de la politique doucement subtilement et
surtout pas de manière frontale
si on y va de façon frontale là où
d'autres personnes va se renfermer dans
ses convictions par exemple si on essaye
de lui montrer des preuves ou des
chiffres encore davantage leurs enfermé
dans sa conviction il va s'en aller et
du coup il va aller se renfermer dans
des groupes qui pensent déjà ce qu'ils
pensent et du coup notre effort pour le
convaincre de notre opinion en fait
complètement détriment talent ne parlons
pas que des sujets qui les visent
surtout à des gens qu'on ne connaît pas
et j'espère que vous avez remarqué que
cet épisode comme n'importe quel média
du web à ses propres convictions
construite à l'intérieur d'eux
de cette vidéo la conviction qui est
dans cette vidéo c'est que les
conditions sont virales et ce qui serait
cool c'est que la conviction selon
laquelle les convictions sont générales
deviennent vieira depuis pour cela
pensez à partager cette vidéo vous voyez
que l'on rentre de plus en plus autant
des sujets de plus en plus petit ce sera
de plus en plus le cas au fur et à
mesure que l'on approche des élections
présidentielles second tour de
l'élection présidentielle
on va rentrer dans l'estrie que je peux
vous dire que j'ai passé beaucoup
beaucoup de temps et écrire et réécrire
les scripts pourra essayer de minimiser
au maximum et contresens possible dans
cette vidéo c'est vraiment que les
choses soient le plus clair possible
et la prochaine fois en particulier on
va parler d'un sujet ultra 2 qui va
parler du principe fondamental de la
politique
selon rose bénodet mesquida et d'autres
chercheurs en sciences politiques
donc j'espère vraiment que vous serez la
prochaine fois puisqu'on va parler d'une
théorie qui a complètement bouleversé ma
façon de comprendre la politique
car si vous avez aimé cet épisode penser
à de l'ikea le commenter à le partager
pensez à vous abonner pour ne pas
manquer les futurs épisodes merci aussi
peur pour leurs dons et j'espère que je
verrai la prochaine fois